تاريخ هذا الشريط غير مؤكد حتى الان نرى
فيه مرتزقه روس وهم يلوحون بعلم مجموعه
فاجنر ويتراقصون في شرق بخموت انها صور
دعائيه موجهه الى القوات الاوكرانيه لوهن
عزيمتها الهجوم الروسي على باخمو تم وصفه
بانه بلا هوادا في محاوله لتطويق هذه
المدينه الشرقيه في اوكرانيا ليس بعيدا
الى الغرب من باخموت
في مدينه شاسي فيار سمع شهود عيان ذوي
القصف المدفعي
الشوارع تبدو خاليه والابنيه متضرره بشكل
كبير السكان تركوا المدينه مع اشتداد
المعارك في المنطقه سنترك المنطقه بقينا
الى اخر لحظه اردنا البقاء لكن تم تدمير
الشقه التي كنا فيها حان وقت الرحيل
كنت املك شقه في الحي الثامن في بخموت لم
يعد فيه حجر على حجر جاهدت كل حياتي
لاشتري تلك الشقه لم اعد اخشى شيئا ابلغ
من العمر 70 عاما ولدي سبعه احفاد لم اعد
اخشى شيئا خلال الاسابيع الماضيه تقدمت
القوات الروسيه في عدد من البلدات والمدن
المحيطه ببخموت القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت
مصره على الاحتفاظ بالمدينه على الرغم من
التقدم الروسي البطيء الذي تسبب باغلاق
اغلب الطرق المؤديه اليها